SK Telecom coming back after being two
down there goes a nexus GG eventually
the time comes for a player to go to the
army so he only has so many
opportunities remaining Gor the guy who
does have a single title to his name for
years score chased victory and failed
over and over time was running out and
it seemed like he would be doomed to
retire as the best to never win they
take down kt rolster they put another
championship final on their belt the
problem is that what it matters most
they just [ __ ] up but score refused to
give up that's getting aggressive
forcing the exhaust down near score the
flash head they're going to go onto the
wall this could be first blood going on
over to score low one more dance will
finish off that rock on over to the
scoreboard interesting starts that we've
seen the score gonna go ahead despite
the red buff to get some HP back but
Haru leap city flashes it but smeb ends
up coming up with that first blood a
score played that as well as you could
and what was this a super unlikely
circumstance that was some insane
mechanics this is going to be a true
50/50 is they are gonna stop the
teamfight instead
[Music]
for is one of the greatest league of
legends players of all time but you
wouldn't know it looking at his trophy
case despite playing the game for the
better part of a decade he was entering
the 2018 season without a single trophy
twilight of his career can score finally
pick up the big one that has eluded him
for six and a half years cost in Korea
eventually the time comes for a player
to go to the army so he only has so many
opportunities remaining will score ever
get closer Achilles and time was running
out
scorer was getting ready to retire which
meant there was a real chance he would
end his career without any legacy to
speak of he'd be forgotten and cast
aside as the best to never win because
you see score was one of the best four
years people called him the best jungler
in the world and some even considered
him to be the best jungler of all time
but before he was the god of the jungle
score held down ball way as an ad carry
scores career started at the very
beginning of Korean League of Legends he
started playing in 2011 as Joker in
ozians inaugural champions tournament
score was there from day one of Korean
league to put that into perspective
his jungler on star tail was koma who
went on to become SK he's a legendary
coach but after one year squirrel left
star tail to join what would become his
permanent home kt rolster thanked the kt
rolster bullets became one of korea's
best teams in 2013 even winning
international tournaments like MLG and
the asian indoor martial arts game
meanwhile score wasn't making a name for
himself with his defensive play style
earning the nickname the immortal but
despite all of their successes there was
one team that kept kt rolster from
lifting the 2013 summer trophy SKT I
think slam dunk a lot of damage on top
of that bob w gets
kill on sight but SK Telecom coming it
over the top and store trap piglet gets
the kill goes on to faker faker backs
off a bit and look at Ryu
he knows this / champion summer is over
SK Telecom coming back after being too
down there goes a nexus GG incredible
reversal kill coming out of SK Telecom
getting several hole early and this is
exactly what we saw last champion suffer
as well squirrel lost his first domestic
title in what is now considered one of
the most iconic series in the League of
Legends history the bullets declined in
2014 and ended the year with a pretty
disappointing result their only real
highlight that season was winning I am
kind of beat say but they were the only
Korean team competing so it didn't
really count as much but just because
score wasn't finding success didn't mean
that Kate he wasn't well the bullets
were struggling their sister team the kt
rolster arrows became champions are they
going for it are they going for the win
oh my gosh I don't know if they have
time they're going for the first Nexus
right now for the second axis
is that Miss Katie arrows gonna take it
right here this is going down all they
need to do is swap consent oh my god
yeah
[Applause]
[Applause]
so at the end of the year when Katie had
to merge their two teams to take part in
rious new Korean League score had an
important decision to make
he could either stay with the team and
fight arrow a rising star and a reigning
champion for the starting 80 Harry
fought or he could do something a little
different and very interestingly enough
as we go down to the end of the roster
there's not a wait what's this in the
support role that's score guys that
score he was an ad carry on kt rolster B
for a very long time they're trying him
out today as the jungler on this new kt
rolster squad crazy stuff now score way
way way back when on star tail used to
play in the top lane so this isn't even
his first Lane swap but it is his first
swap in quite a while
Gore had a rough start of junglers KT
failed to even make it to the playoffs
in spring 2015 but over the next two
years score one from a jungle newbie to
a jungle god that started playing that
little interaction for the Bogside
oh nice all from score praise nearly
take it down immediately piccaboo help
score pick that one up in gorilla house
the flash get stun goes down there's a
kill for arrow he's gonna flash right
back in this Baker gets way too many
scores says all right you wanna play
this game let's go bro from score they
take him down fly fights to kill and
Kurt called up they want to give that
one over to arrow unable to do it and
score good problems he just was too much
damage
the former ad carry turned into not only
the best jungler in Korea but the world
his early passing was incredible and he
had this unbelievable ability to always
be in the right place at the right time
but in classic kt fashion there was a
catch
score may have been the best jungler in
the world but he still couldn't win
anything it's not necessary because they
are going
seek a summer and they are going to get
a spotted world to get there it is
brunch tigers taken GG it's about time
it was like clockwork score made the
summer finals where he inevitably lost
no matter how much hype Katie had going
in after failing to make worlds in 2016
Katie blew up their roster they kept
score but they added four superstars in
the top lane there was some med
considered to be the best player in the
world in 2016
pawn and death came from EDG as Katie's
new carry and rounding out the team was
Amada the greatest support in a league
of Legends history and then there was
score oh yeah
and it turns out that scores condition
was contagious
he quickly infected his superstar
teammates with the second-place curse on
SKT t1 in the early game Katie were
second to none their laners were
incredible and scores fantastic passing
and decision-making turn those early
lead in to pressure and objectives but
once they hit the 20-minute mark
everything started to fall apart
sure Katie could get all the early
leaves they wanted but they couldn't
close games goals sure not gonna find a
lot of time as the Banshees male gonna
be an all-out brawl Smith goes in a
rather deep but he is just gonna pop
scores and you find some fight double
delivery coming through and that might
just be a true fight to kill
go down three members dead samsung push
again now looking for pawn captain jack
be damned this might be the greatest
base defense in the history of league of
legends how did they do it but this long
they can prove forward through there's
no that time is available here Casey is
too long they've actually done it
they're gonna knock down the turrets
Samsung Galaxy will be kt rolster a 3-0
victory and score does his damndest to
stop it but there's just no avail
he will fail the Nexus will crumble and
Samsung Galaxy are going to Worlds
alongside SK Telecom headlong shoot
gaming those authors must have stung for
a team designed to win world but for
score they hurt even more because with
every defeat his window to win shrank he
deferred his mandatory Korean military
service plenty of times but he couldn't
defer it anymore the 2019 season would
be his last and if he didn't win then he
would never win it seemed like scorer
was doomed to retire as the best to
never win he'd go out with a wasted
legacy and eventually he'd be forgotten
cast off and faded from memory as
leagues forgotten God but in the 2018
summer split scorer gave it his all for
one last shot score could also be
camping for him and speaking a camp I
was worried about the to be one but the
three view one can they pull it off
Tina's gonna apprehend the boat but
actually they didn't even need Mata to
come in this is going to be a true 50/50
as they are gonna stop the team fight
instead SKT the beam comes down they
manage to find one but smeb goes and
gets rid of the gnar and kt rolster
congratulations you have finally done it
you've met at yourself a first place
Whittier in the summer split you're
going all the way to Grand Finals on
September 8th score was used to being in
the finals he was just used to losing
them instead of winning but his
opponents they weren't used to being in
the finals at all they qualified for the
grand final they keep they keep Africa
freaks from running the whole way and
they could do it they do better than SK
Telecom t1 K could for years
five years ago it doesn't matter in the
first season they make it to the grand
final and the dream is on against kt
rolster Griffin grey team of rookie and
their jungler Carson was already
challenging scores reputation as the
best jungler in the world so what's
gonna be fought over classic slingshot
comes in gets the grab here on to ian
flashes a hip nap traps it back over the
wall and he is that dead man towers down
looking for his angles justice doesn't
have cleanse we see if something can
happen here perfect angle no flash into
the shockwave it looks like he's gonna
just hold on to it as first blood does
go over to rather in the mid lane look
at this
they've got so much single target damage
onto this Baathists or Todd's gonna go
once again the odds were stacked against
score but his teammates most of whom
were already champions had just one goal
to help score finally cement his place
in history
the world will deal with all the fans
were definitely very instrumental to the
win today their support was phenomenal
and I really wanted us to win and I'm
really sad that I couldn't give this win
to my past teammates Katie teammates I
wish they were here as well that was
scores first and the last time lifting
in lck trophy the team failed to win
world 2018 and score spent his final
season splitting time with and mentoring
Katie's new jungle recruit on T and that
year at the age of 27 score retired I
don't know what to say
I think this will be my last lck game
today
thank you for all the fans who have been
supporting me and also enjoying watching
our games so I will keep doing my best
thank you in the world of eSports the
brightest stars shine for just a second
before they fizzle out but score never
gave up he never stopped playing until
the government came in and literally
told him he couldn't anymore he proved
that at least in the league of legends
age is just a number bit one I think it
done in a food for some seeing score
lift the lck trophy was all the
validation he would ever need but four
score he even need some trophy to prove
he was one of the best of all time his
career might be full of disappointments
but it's the result of a man who never
gave up a man who overcame crushing
defeats a major role swap in a ticking
clock on his career to become one of the
game's unforgettable legends score truly
is immortal
[Music]
country
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
Honda motor do annyeonghi Tamara [ __ ]
ooh
Anya Gagne
[Applause]
[Music]